what's the difference to you between
Oblivion Skyrim Morrowind oblivious
Skyrim and uh Elder Scrolls
like I could to me man stuff Blends
together yeah uh but Oblivion
that's when you can make spells and
stuff
you could you could do it in Morrowind
as well Oblivion has some more
guardrails on it
morrowind's where you can really go and
Daggerfall
again
I don't remember if you can make spells
in Arena I think you can
someone will correct me you definitely
can and Daggerfall gets crazy Morrowind
um you can sum up and then we start we
start putting guard rails on it because
people started
breaking the game in certain ways yeah
why is it bad to break the game like you
always want it to be well there's like
one people love in Morrowind where you
can make these uh recall stones
and uh you could teleport to different
areas but you really need in that game
it breaks so many quests yeah and so as
we any any Quest we were then we would
do this this exercise of Designing a
quest and then someone would say and
then I recall away okay the quest is
broken and then one day someone says can
we just get rid of that spell effect
everyone's like yes please and so it
allowed us to make better content